here's a fun topic um cremation Oh
wicked we talked about this I know I
know I know we talked about I just wanna
that gonna be burned up okay I don't
know how would you like it if somebody
set you on fire no thank you
well it's not like they light you you
know I don't like camping and I know
like fires and I don't want to be
personally lit on fire I want to be
frozen do they have that as an option
how you doing Sacramento that are New
York City boy in the house you're not
too good for us now are you
I'm glad that you're moving home for a
bit your mom's gonna need a lot of help
don't look at us were drug addicts I
thought you didn't want to try Medical
Marijuana well I tried it was just
pretty today's I feel like sue settle
you know your mother was supposed to be
born dead so she's still very very lucky
how grandpa asked her doctor
I mean he's dead but if he wasn't you
could he hung himself that's true I'll
be Tom and he's been Donna outside I
can't stand to see him licking his penis
no no no stop does anybody have any
questions
yeah what's going on it's not my DA you
got to live your life except you can't
date anyone for a year and you can't
date that who came to the door
today when I saw let's just travel the
whole world real quick did you see
everything I get to see my whole world
at dinner tonight all I ever wanted was
to be a mother I thought when your mom
dies you get that beautiful revelation
about life
and just everything becomes clear one
just feels like something that happens
to other people take the place of you
know your other people's other people
remember that one that I bought in the
Internet
I looked it up and it doesn't cure
cancer well